je vais vous faire jouer à qui est
l'invité des 4V je vous donne un indice
un premier Monsieur Patate
je sais pas 2e
du pont et du pont alors
tintinaise exactement manifester oui
bloquer non c'est ce que vient de dire
le porte-parole du gouvernement Olivier
vérances exprimait à l'issue du conseil
des ministres il juge inacceptable les
menaces de la CGT qui veut couper le
courant aux élus qui soutiennent la
réforme dont il réaffirme par ailleurs
la nécessité et Monsieur Patate c'est
quoi c'est c'est collaborateurs et il a
même un monsieur Patate il me raconte un
jour sur son bureau voilà c'est pour ça
que je me suis permis de c'est vrai que
Monsieur Patate à la CGT j'ai des pas du
tout merci pour l'info et vous de
regarder plus jamais Monsieur Patate de
la même manière elle a 28 ans mais elle
est retraité il y a
joker pour l'aider c'est peut-être ça
Manon la retraité il y a deux
moi je prends ma retraite à 72 ans au
Danemark est-ce que vous voyez la France
évaluée vers cette système là où est-ce
que le fond que on a sur la table
maintenant c'est bon c'est fini 71% des
Français soutiennent le mouvement de
grève contre la réforme des retraites
résultat d'un sondage à risque
interactive taux d'une heure pour RTL et
AEF ils sont par ailleurs 72% à juger
cette réforme injuste
une augmentation salariale tout de suite
de 2000 euros pour l'ensemble des
salariés le SMIC et un départ on
retraite à 50 ans à temps plein c'est ça
le revendication
[Rires]
de se déplacer la SNCF et la RATP
recommande d'ailleurs au voyageur et
bien de tout simplement de pas se
déplacer et privilégier le télétravail
pour cette journée de grève peut-être la
première d'une longue série puisque les
syndicats et bien l'annonce ce mouvement
est reconductible
françaises grands-parents grande parent
papy mamie pépé mémé Papou Mamou l'heure
est grave nous avons besoin de vous les
papiers et les mamies manifestez-vous
aujourd'hui et appelez vos enfants ayez
pour eux ce message clair
voilà j'ai peur Benjamin coucou si tu
veux demain je te garde les enfants
voilà la France et vos enfants vous
offrant reconnaissants au nom du pays
chers papy chère mamie je vous en
remercie c'était la locution moi j'ai
une demande à l'attention spécifique de
BFM spécifique allons-y parce que une
journée comme celle-ci c'est une journée
il faut l'envisager un peu comme un
tournage c'est comme un tournage avec
une feuille de service à 7 heures du
matin les images sur les forces voilà la
veille des informations sur les CRS et
compagnies est-ce que j'aimerais c'est
qu'il y ait des moyens de tournage qui
soit qui soit de hauteur qu'on voit
cette masse qu'on voit la grande avenue
pleine que peuvent-ils bien montrer en
exclusivité une veille de jours de grève
on va voir vous montrer en exclusivité
la banderole qui sera déployée demain
dans le dans le cortège parisien la
banderole de la grève en exclusivité sur
BFM et nulle part ailleurs et ce n'était
pas la seule exclu et oui je suis en
mesure de vous révéler en exclusivité
les saucisses qui seront grillés demain
en marge de la manifestation que vous
faisiez pas le petit plan là le plan
serré sur la bribus un peu abîmée à 10h
du matin qui va effrayer madame et
monsieur tout le monde je pense qu'on a
tous aussi un rôle c'est évident c'est
évident que dans le traitement des
mouvements par le gouvernement
est en train de nous expliquer comment
on doit filmer une manif
et puis exclusivité absolue vous pouvez
déjà découvrir la moustache carborera
Philippe Martinez entre la Place de la
Bastille et la place de la Nation demain
parler du tout parler des Français et
trouver les moyens techniques de le
faire voilà j'en ai fini sur le requête
c'est vrai que demain on va on n'aura
pas du tout envie de montrer l'ampleur
s'il y a beaucoup de monde on n'aura pas
du tout évidemment évidemment
la Garenne vous savez bien et je veux
dire à nos partenaires européens la
France est en train de changer elle
change beaucoup plus vite et beaucoup
plus profondément qu'on le croit
désormais quand il y a une grève en
France personne ne s'en aperçoit
alors ça ça c'était en juillet 2008 vous
aurez bien sûr reconnu Nicolas Sarkozy
nous ne voulons plus en France 2
milliardaires nous nous voulons une
France 100 milliardaires
[Applaudissements]
à quoi ça sert un milliardaire
sérieusement à quoi ça sert un
milliardaire on nous répond
ruissellement c'est faux on nous répond
il crée de l'emploi non celles et ceux
qui les créent c'est nous c'est vous
c'est le monde du travail
oui je suis millionnaire
j'ai pas compté mais je suis
multimillionnaire pour être honnête avec
vous parfois je me dis j'ai trop
d'argent j'ai même plus quoi en faire et
je veux que le gouvernement prenne plus
de mon argent qu'il me taxe plus 200
millionnaires ont demandé aux dirigeants
bandoux à être plus taxés oui requête
qui est très vite et très bien arrivée
aux oreilles de Bruno Le Maire s'ils
veulent s'installer en France ils sont
les bienvenus ils ont droit au taux
d'imposition parmi les plus élevées
plein la tranche enlève-moi une part
vous serez d'une des personnes les plus
taxées au monde et donc vous serez
heureux merci dernier la capitalisation
boursière de LVMH a dépassé les 400
milliards d'euros à course de Paris
alors si ça ne vous parle pas sachez que
c'est la toute première fois de
l'histoire qu'une société européenne
atteint ce niveau symbolique Bernard
Arnault le patron de LVMH qui fédère 70
maisons d'exception Guerlain ou encore
Dom Pérignon Louis Vuitton troisième
plus grand employeur français en 2018
145247 salariés
13500 emplois créés c'est-à-dire là son
groupe embauche beaucoup d'ailleurs en
moyenne entre 2500 et 3000 salariés par
an mais est-ce que les pauvres sont plus
heureux quand les riches sont moins
nombreux dans tes riches sont moins
nombreux ou qu'il y a plus de riches je
ne le l'expérience montre que ce n'est
pas forcément le cas
consulter vos souvenirs d'enfants ils
sont bien plus sages que vos délires
d'adultes
[Applaudissements]